Arrested Development people obviously
love the show coming back will it be
would be the entire cast is everyone
coming I got the whole cast sadly even
Bateman and we tried to keep that real
quiet and he picked up on it I guess I
mean he tried to have an Arrested
Development reunion without bait yeah we
tried our damndest I'll tell you and he
you know he's just I got I love him he's
just so bland and Institute discredit
him as an actual official cure for
insomnia no really just just when he
talks now that what some people don't
know this when he gets on an airplane
he's not allowed to talk to the pilots
[Laughter]
you and Bateman have been pals for a
long time does he mind when you go after
him does it bother him on any level or
can he take it he he can take it he's
pretty good at taking it you know I
thought you were better than that I'm
not better than that
I know truthfully I saw him yesterday I
said you know I'm going on Conan
tomorrow and I just have to be honest on
the show and like let everybody know how
I feel about I love him we i rib him all
the time we actually have a text chain
and we're constantly putting up pictures
and backs and forth and whatever and I
keep finding photos of him when he was a
kid he was a child actor just doing like
the dumbest like poses you know teen
beat or whatever and what how does he
respond when you show these hands the
other day he was in he was in Atlanta
and he was like working he was directing
I knew he was super busy so it was the
right time and I sent him this picture
and all he simply replied on the chain
he was the only one who replaced him
everybody
you've ruined my day I think we have it
don't we I brought a couple of things
let's take a look at some of these
pictures
[Applause]
hochy hey why is he holding he's going
to eat something my son saw this picture
of with it with the lipstick on his
cheek he's like ah don't show me that
he's got girls kissing him I guess and
by the way he's got his name on his Jack
he still wears that yeah I think we have
another one I just want to see oh my god
that's when he was on Sun alive let's
take another one oh the ladder never
lean on a ladder when you're an actor
you just happen to plug that ladder
pretty sweet so you put your just
constantly barage in here with photos he
regrets from his childhood yes and it's
just the way to keep him in line you
know cuz he he's just got a he can get
you know um you both dumb he can get a
little big headed you know and that's
actually not true he's such a sweet guy
towards her
you